this is the university of kentucky's
horticulture research farm where the
students planted their cover crop
mixture about six weeks ago
this was a day to collect samples and
data
each student planted a different
combination of cover crops
victor halmos a uk graduate student
studying entomology planted a mixture of
sorghum sudan grass oil seed radish and
hairy vetch one of the first things i
that i noticed was
my third cover crop the hairy vetch was
out competed by the tillage radish
probably because of shade shade
competition uk senior suzanne deeb had a
similar discovery with her cover crop
combination of hairy vetch bastard and
buckwheat
and it was really interesting to see
how it actually like comes out in real
life and see the reality of like hey
these plants like compete with each
other for resources and maybe don't
combine them
deeb and halmos and their uk classmates
were part of nearly 80 college students
from seven u.s universities in a class
co-taught by uk weed scientist aaron
harimoto and instructors from the other
schools
the hybrid class includes in-person
exercises and virtual discussions over
zoom the students study cover crops in a
variety of agricultural systems to
maximize their benefits and minimize
their negative aspects so there are some
very real challenges to using them that
kind of limit their adoption in addition
to the fact that they cost money a lot
of the benefits they provide accumulate
over longer term
and
so there's often not a real economic
incentive to use them in the short term
a lot of farmers do use cover crops and
kentucky is in the top 20 of percentage
of acreage in cover crops
nationwide there's been an increase in
cover crops but remains pretty small
one of the exercises the students
participated in the class was a way to
measure soil health through microbial
activity it's called soil your undies
and so you they have this this activity
where you can go bury
a very specific brand of underwear in
different parts of your fields or fields
that are under different management
practices
and then the
you leave it in there for a set period
of time the more the underwear is
degraded or decomposed the more
biological activity there is in your
soil
once a week the uk students meet with
their counterparts over zoom and are
divided into small groups to discuss
what they have discovered in exercises
that week from the university of
kentucky college of agriculture food and
environment i'm jeff franklin
you